good evening i'm lieutenant ray spencer
i'm the homicide lieutenant with the las
vegas metropolitan police
thank all of you for coming out here
this evening because we need all of your
help and the community's support and
help in this case
just to recap this morning at around
eight o'clock this morning
hikers in the area of mountain pass off
of
the highway leading to pahrump near blue
diamond state route 160
located the body of what we believe to
be a
10 year old hispanic juvenile
now the details that i'm going to share
right now are still fluid so again
we believe he's around 10 years of age
he is
4 foot 11 123 pounds
we're going to show a photograph now
this here is a photograph that was
conducted by our department sketch
artist
of our victim i do want to share though
when you look at the photograph
it's hard when the sketch artist is
drawing doing the drawing he is actually
a lot more fuller in the chin
again he looks a little older in this
photograph he's about a 10 year old
hispanic juvenile
411 123 pounds
anyone who recognizes
this young man is urged to contact lvmpd
homicide
your information will remain completely
anonymous
you can call crime stoppers or directly
we have
uh people manning the telephones right
now at 702-828-352-3521 that is our
homicide office
and we have detectives that will take
your call right now
again i'll take a couple questions but
again i'm still going to keep a lot of
things
vague at this point because it is an
active and ongoing investigation with a
tremendous amount of resources working
right now
yes and what type of priorities
well again i can tell you that the
department is doing
absolutely everything that we can we
have detectives from all over the agency
working from a variety of different on
a variety of different aspects trying to
identify
this young man so everything that we can
do we are doing that's why we are here
right now this is the second conference
that i've done
and i urge your viewers to please
contact us
someone has to recognize this young man
it could be a neighbor it could be a
friend of the family
something that would lead investigators
in a direction where we can
get him identified in this investigation
yes
do you have any current missing children
so we have actively went through not
just las vegas metro reports we've been
in contact with henderson north las
vegas san bernardino nye county
no agencies in the immediate area have
any children that match this description
so
that's why we're here right now and how
does that change the course of the
investigation
well again it's paramount that we're
able to
identify him so we can begin the
the key points of this investigation so
again any tip regardless of how small
you think that tip
is please contact the numbers that i
gave you
in the back has the investigation
determined when approximately
has this kid passed away uh we believe
that within the last 24 hours as of this
morning so
sometime in the last 24 hours would be
our time of death
yes
i'm not going to get in any specifics at
this point on
injuries or anything as far as what led
us to being here
yes
so we have officers all along state
route 160 we're canvassing from video
again from perrump
all the way to i-15 so officers are not
actually at the specific scene
but again you know we have a tremendous
amount of resources working
uh on this case right now can you
describe the
type of closing i'm not going to get in
any specifics of at the crime scene so
thank you guys i appreciate it and any
help again
is appreciated thank you